it is March 12 2023 and you're watching
the code report a bank is one of the
easiest businesses to run all you have
to do is collect money and not
things up unfortunately the banker
behind many high-profile Tech startups
did not follow this Rule and was shut
down and seized by the FDIC on Friday
we up now people who work at
startups that keep their cash at Silicon
Valley Bank have been freaking out
because they're worried that their
paychecks might bounce or their cash
burning employers might collapse but is
that even realistic well there's a lot
to entangle here first if you're not
already familiar with the situation let
me get you up to speed over the last
decade we lived through a tech boom that
was even bigger than the.com bubble
thanks to easy money and low interest
rates from central banks all you needed
was the next big idea for a disruptive
app to get an investment from a venture
capital firm all you need are some
slides and PowerPoint about why Tinder
for horses makes the world a better
place than some guy in a Patagonia vest
gives you 10 million dollars you're a
tech bro now and need to put that money
somewhere and who better than Silicon
Valley Bank things were great for svb
when interest rates were low and it
became the 16th largest bank in the
United States with around 175 billion in
customer deposits to make a return on
this cash they invested in bonds and
mortgage-backed securities often with 10
or more years to maturity the problem is
that when interest rates go up bond
prices go down and this led to a
mismatch between assets and liabilities
when people got wind of this it led to
an Old-Fashioned to run on the bank
where everybody started to panic and
withdraw their money the government who
ensures deposits up to 250 thousand
dollars stepped in quickly and shut down
the bank to minimize their losses sounds
pretty crazy but who's actually going to
lose money here well if you have less
than 250k in this bank then you lose
nothing because that money is fully
insured however most tech startups
likely have more than that in the bank
and at least 85 percent of deposits were
uninsured and that money could end up
getting a haircut
the situation is ongoing and there's a
few different things that could happen
here a bigger Bank could swoop in and
acquire svb and guarantee all the
deposits if that doesn't work maybe
they'll create some legislation to Rob
money from the taxpayers to bail out
these Tech startups just like they did
with big banks in 2008 but if that
doesn't work the FDIC can just liquidate
all of the assets of svb then pay out a
future dividend to uninsured depositors
that's as good as money sir those are
ious so at the end of the day depositors
will get most if not all of their money
back shareholders though are pretty much
screwed they got bailed in and now face
a total loss luckily though the bank's
top Executives were able to sell
millions of dollars in stock over the
last few weeks so they'll be just fine
the most interesting thing about this
situation though is the contagion
contagion or what kind of economic
shocks will this create for other
businesses in Silicon Valley U.S decoin
one of the top stable coins in crypto
depeged as a result because more than 3
billion of its cash reserves were
exposed to svb this looks really bad for
crypto because these stable coins are
necessary to keep liquidity in the
crypto markets if it were to collapse
entirely there would be a ton of
collateral damage the collapse of
terra's UST last year was pretty bad but
the collapse of usdc would be far worse
when it comes to Contagion it makes you
wonder if there are any other banks in a
similar situation to svb it was uniquely
exposed to Tech startups but the key
problem here is rising interest rates
and there are likely other Banks out
there that made similar mistakes but
most importantly how will this affect
the average software engineer who works
at a startup exposed to s SBB many
companies like Roku and Roblox have
disclosed their exposure and should have
no problem continuing their operations
as normal then you have other smaller
startups saying that they're not going
to be able to meet their payroll that
sounds bad but in reality they'll likely
be able to find some kind of temporary
solution to continue operating as normal
until the FDIC gets things figured out
longer term though this is definitely
bad news for the tech job market running
out of money is never a good thing
especially in an industry where it's
normal to burn through tons of cash
until you get acquired or IPO to make
matters worse inflation was worse than
expected recently which means the fed's
not going to be able to ease interest
rates anytime soon there's really only
two possible outcomes interest rates
stay high and we enter the Great
Depression 2.0 or interest rates go low
and the dollar hyper inflates into
worthless toilet paper in either case it
doesn't matter because AI is going to
replace all these tech jobs anyway and
that's why you should learn to mine as
soon as possible this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one